hello and welcome to part three in our
series on the visual effects of the
infiltrator tech demo today we're going
to take a look at the fireball effect
that was seen about halfway through that
demonstration and joining me is senior
visual effects artist Francois Antoine
hey Francois hey Zack how are you doing
well so why don't you start by telling
us a little bit about yourself
sure so before coming an epoch I worked
in film visual effects for ten years and
I'm excited about this demo today
because we're going to be showing an
explosion which uses some of the same
techniques that we use in film visual
effects so can you maybe give us a kind
of an overview of what's so special
about this effect well we had to create
this explosion with a new technique
called the volume texture and it's
basically a texture that's
three-dimensional and that in
combination with GPU particles allowed
us to create what we call our volume
explosion traditionally sprite-based
explosions don't have the cohesive feel
but the volume explosion kind of
overcomes those limitations and give the
impression that it's really rolling
through the geometry and expanding so
the first step was to create the data
for the volume explosion and for that I
went into 3d studio max and use the fume
FX plugin to generate a 3d fluid
simulation and you can see that here we
imported the geometry from Unreal Engine
and using FBX it actually saves the
placement of all the geometry and also
allows you to import camera with the
camera angle and the length different
lens settings which I imagine would be
useful here where you kind of need to
wrap a fluid simulation around them yeah
absolutely actually having the camera
allows you to really customize and
animate to the camera which can be a big
time-saver so you don't waste time
animating things that won't be seen on
the camera once we have the explosion
going what I did is that I rendered ten
cross-sections of the fluid simulation
from a top-down point of view and you
can see that each of these
cross-sections is represented by the
volume between each of these planes so
these are now rendered out and one of
the cross-sections looks just like this
and you can actually see inside the
explosion
there because this is a middle a
cross-section all right so once I had
all these cross-sections rendered out I
brought them together inside After
Effects and over here you can see on the
left here I have all ten cross-sections
stacked on top of each other this was
just a way to test to make sure that
there were no rendering artifacts or
shadows from one layer into another and
it was to make sure everything was
properly sorted before bringing that
information into Unreal Engine so now
we're going to import each of these
slices as a sub UV texture so this is
one of the bottom most layers you can
see the cross-section for each of the
frames of the render and I imagine this
would be one of the lower slices that's
exactly right as the explosion moves up
it just leaves behind smoke so what we
can do is look at one of the higher
level fireball slices and you can see
here that you have nothing in the
beginning because the fireball hasn't
reached that area of the fluid
simulation and then the top
cross-section is right here so the next
step is to recreate the information
between each of these slices so here we
are inside the material that we wrote
you can see here there's a note called
the volume texture sample and this is
where we create the 3d volume texture it
is also a function as you can see it's
highlighted in blue a function is
basically a network of nodes that can be
reused very easily kind of like a
snippet of code and this was created by
artists you didn't have to bring in a
coder to write this that's right yes and
that's where the power of unreal is is
that we can actually prototype these
kinds of features using artists tools so
you can see right here we have more
functions and each of these functions
reference one of the slices that we
rendered out earlier and brought into an
real engine you also see there's also
extra parameters here that a artist can
set which is like the XY size of the
volume and the slicing between the space
between each slices so a little bit of
further customization if you need it
later yes and because these are
parameters then they will be exposed to
the material instance which will plug in
later for the explosion very nice okay
so you've got your material at this
point what's the next step so the next
step is to actually be able to display
that volume texture typically a way to
display one texture is to retrace it but
that is very expensive so
we didn't want to use that approach so
instead what we're using is a point
cloud of particles and what's going to
happen is that each of these particle is
going to look up a certain point in
space of the volume texture and display
those color values so I noticed the
particles aren't moving we're looking at
this in wireframe right now so I guess
each one of these is kind of like a
static monitor that's exactly right yet
the motion is not in the particles it is
in the texture that is actually animated
so we basically just need a lot of tiny
little billboards that will sample that
texture okay and display it so they're
not moving for that reason so right here
we have about 500 GPU particles with GPU
particle system that's the right amount
when we're kind of far from the camera
but here because we're looking at
exposure pretty closely I'm going to
increase that count just for the sake of
visualizing the explosion up close so
2,000 particles is still very cheap by
GPU standards so now we can see the
explosion happening and if we go to the
top view which is where our camera is
for the shot well that is amazing you
can actually feel it like creeping up at
the camera yes and that's exactly the
feeling we wanted that's something we
don't traditionally get with regular 2d
sprite explosions because they don't
have that coherence between each other
and they don't have this kind of growing
volume very nice
so because it's made of slices if you
switch to the side view you'll be able
to see what our material is doing you
can see each of the ten slices in effect
here and you can see our material is
creating interpolated data between each
of these slices so in effect we're
recreating the explosion accurately from
the top down but using more efficient
interpolated data where we don't need
the detail right so it's not going to be
perfect from all angles but you've still
got a wide range of visible areas and a
lot of motion and depth in the overall
effect exactly if we needed to see this
explosion from the side we probably
would have increased the quality the
number of slices or used a different
technique all together but for what we
need which is some subtle parallax and
that the rolling motion this is a just a
right fit for that shot awesome so you
can see here on the output of our volume
texture node we're plugging into the
black body node what's special about the
black body node is I takes in a
temperature and Kelvin and returns a
color
effect this allows us to color explosion
in a more realistic way no more I guess
having to fight and figure out what the
best color for fire is yes that's right
awesome
okay so the next step is to get it into
the cinematic so we could see it so I
created a number of tracks in the
cinematic tool which is matinee you can
see I'm triggering the explosion using
the toggle track for the explosion and
that's just going to turn on the
explosion and that's all that's great
that just triggers the explosion and has
it running but because we wanted to sit
better in the environment I create also
a track with lights and this is called
the explosion light and that just
creates light right here and it kind of
blows out the environment so you really
get the feeling that there's an
explosion going off mm-hmm and on top of
that you can see there's a layer of
distortion right there and the
distortion is just a sheet that has a
distortion material applied to it that
sits on top of the explosion it moves up
with it so as it gets close to the
camera you start getting that feeling of
heat and heat shimmer so if we run
through the cinematic we can see the
completed effect tell me how did Unreal
Engine 4 enable you to make this effect
is this something you could have done
previously it would have been hard to do
previously because we're using a custom
material functions in the material
expression editor and on top of that we
need to use GPU particles
well Francois thank you very much for
your time and thank you for joining us
we will catch you on the next inside
unreal